في الأسابيع التي أعقبت فوز
ترامب في الانتخابات والدائرتين المقربين منه ، سيشنون
حملة ضغط مرتفع ، مرحبًا فرانسيس ، كيف
حالك
مرحبًا براد
وريان والجميع يصرح بأنه رودي جولياني
على الأقل 30 اتصالًا بين ترامب
والمسؤولين الجمهوريين في ولايات حاسمة
جورجيا ميشيغان بنسلفانيا
وأريزونا
هذا  هو عامل البيت الأبيض الذي
كنت بالخارج لتناول العشاء مع الأصدقاء
وجاءت مكالمة هاتفية من واشنطن
العاصمة برقم لم
أتعرف على كلينت هيكمان وهو مؤيد ترامب الذي كان
حينها رئيس مجلس المشرفين في مقاطعة ماريكوبا أريزونا
ولم أصدقه  لقد
كنت أتصل لإعلامك بأن
الرئيس متاح لتلقي مكالمتك
مجانًا ، اترك المكالمة تنتقل إلى
البريد الصوتي بعد أيام ، رفض عامل البيت الأبيض الذي
اتصل
بهيكمان مرة أخرى استلامه ،
ومن الواضح أنني اعتقدت أنه سيكون
شيئًا ما  تفعل بشأن
الانتخابات والعمليات ولم أكن
مستعدًا للحديث عن أن حاكم
ولاية أريزونا قد صدق عليها بالفعل
كمحامي  كشف الجنرال أريزونا
ووزير الخارجية
عن تسجيلاته الآن عشرات
الرسائل النصية والمكالمات الهاتفية المتعددة من
البيت الأبيض من رودي جولياني
وأيضًا رئيس حزب أريزونا الجمهوري ،
لقد تحدثت للتو مع الرئيس ترامب
وهو يريدني أن أفعل ذلك.  التحدث معك في
محاولة للضغط على
المشرفين الجمهوريين في مقاطعة ماريكوبا
للتدخل في انتخابات حرة ونزيهة ،
حيث فاز جو بايدن بالمشرف ، يعتقد بيل غيتس
أنه كان هجومًا على
الدستور ، رأيت أن بريدًا صوتيًا قد
ظهر ، وكان من غير المعقول
سماعه  أنت تعرف على الفور أنني عرفت من
كان ، علمت أن الصوت الذي تعرفه
رودي جولياني عمدة أمريكا فاتورة إنه
رودي جولياني أه محامي الرئيس ترامب
لدي بعض الأشياء التي أود التحدث
عنها معك ربما يمكننا
إصلاح هذا الشيء في ماريكوبا  كان
مجلس المشرفين في المقاطعة قد تلقى للتو
مذكرة الاستدعاء هذه التي تطالب مسؤولي الانتخابات
بتسليم ملايين الأصوات إلى
السياسيين الجمهوريين في الولاية الذين تم
إطلاقهم  في تحقيقات الاحتيال ،
أراد تسليم بطاقات الاقتراع في أقرب وقت
ممكن
حتى يتمكن مجلس الشيوخ من
العمل والبدء في العمل ، وكان
أحد الأهداف هو وضع
أيديهم على ورقة الاقتراع قبل جلسة 6 يناير
في العاصمة التي أرادوا الحصول
على دليل
لدعم إلغاء التصديق على الانتخابات ،
يكون دستورها ملعونًا حقًا ،
أحد الأسباب الرئيسية التي جعلتني أصبح
جمهوريًا في الثمانينيات هو أنني اعتقدت
أن الحزب الجمهوري هو
حزب سيادة القانون ، حزب
الدستور في ميشيغان ، ومقاطعة واين ،
مسؤول الانتخابات الجمهورية  صوتت
للتصديق على الانتخابات ثم غيرت
رأيها بعد مكالمة من دونالد ترامب ،
لقد قدمت لهم نسخة من
إفادة خطية بإلغاء تصويتي في جورجيا
ترامب ليس فقط محقق الانتخابات في الولاية
ولكن كل ما
يمكنك فعله فرانسيس ولكن في ما هو الآن  يجري
التحقيق معه باعتباره جريمة محتملة
حاول ترامب إقناع
وزير خارجية جورج براد رافنسبيرغر
بتغيير فرز الأصوات و
لا حرج في القول إنك تعلم
أه
أنك قد أعدت الحساب ، يبدو من
الواضح والأكثر وضوحًا أن ترامب كان
يحاول بالفعل سرقة الانتخابات ، فقد
كان يحاول بالفعل تهيئة الظروف
التي يُعلن فيها أنه الفائز
على الرغم من أنه خسر
الانتخابات بالفعل.  أمر خطير
ومزعزع للاستقرار
بشكل لا يصدق وربما يكون الأكثر خطورة على الإطلاق ،
حتى أن الرئيس ترامب حاول استخدام
وزارة العدل في الولايات المتحدة
لإنهاء محاولته الانقلابية في
مذكرات مكالمة هاتفية في 27 ديسمبر تم تسليمها الآن
إلى محققي الكونجرس ،
أخبر ترامب القائم بأعمال النائب العام
يقول جيفري روزن ونائبه ريتشارد
دوناهو أن الانتخابات كانت
فاسدة ، اترك الباقي لي وعضو
الكونجرس رفض كلاهما طلب ترامب
وأدلى كلاهما بشهادتهما أمام
اللجنة القضائية بمجلس الشيوخ
برئاسة السناتور ديك دوربين ، ما كان الأمر الأكثر
صدمًا بالنسبة لك
فقط.  كيف كان تورط الرئيس شخصيا بشكل مباشر
هو الضغط الذي كان
يمارسه على JEF  كان فري روزن
حقيقيًا جدًا وكان محددًا جدًا